[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 131 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague as always Melanie work how you
doing Melanie I'm doing good mark how
are you I'm alright but we're not
physically in the same place which makes
me sad not today but we are both still
in San Francisco that is true that is
true so we have some cool stuff
happening today we do so who are we
speaking with yeah we're speaking with
fellow Googler Mandy Chan super-excited
wanted to have them on the podcast for
ages she is a fellow Googler who works
on the actions on Google team so lots of
sounds and voice stuff today should be
really good it's very applicable for a
podcast well before we get into our
interview as always we have our cool
things the week and we also have our
question of the week and this week's
question is I want to push a darker
image to Google container registry via
docker push so how can I set things up
so that I don't have to use g-cloud
docker - - push every time and that will
be a question you'll find out at the end
but as always we're going to start out
with the cool things of the week and
this week we want to kick it off by
mentioning that Google just published
AIX and specifically it's got a blog out
about AI at Google and our principles
and so these principles in particular
you can read them at the link that will
include in our show notes always but I'm
just going to highlight the seven key
ones and they are being socially
beneficial avoid creating or reinforcing
unfair bias be built and tested for
safety be accountable to people
incorporate privacy design principles up
hold high standards of scientific
excellence and be made available for
uses that accord with these principles
and one little note is that that second
one avoid creating a reinforcing unfair
bias that was actually specifically
developed by a team that Margaret
Mitchell was working with and Margaret
Mitchell of course is somebody we
interviewed back in February in regards
to machine learning bias and fairness
yeah no that's great and it's worth
noting as well there is a follow-on
article from Diane Greene CEO of Google
but also in the show notes it's talking
about specifically how Google's AI
principles will be affecting in Google
cloud and how we'll be using those in
Google cloud great mark you got anything
else yeah I want to talk about a great
article that has come out of the Etsy
engineering team I'm probably gonna mask
here this name it says is posted by
I'm gonna say with Torreya Gibbs they
have an article that talks about
basically how they have their deployment
continuous integration system deploying
to a google kubernetes engine instance
as well as their on-prem kubernetes
instance so they basically taking you
away through setting up the Jenkins
infrastructure and the whole deployment
pipeline the build pipeline so it's
definitely worth reading it's a really
cool article great also call out to the
Etsy crew if you ever want to come on
the podcast give us a holla yes it would
be nice to actually get Etsy on and talk
through this too well another cool thing
of the week and this is actually
referenced in the AI ethics list there's
a couple students who are here in
California who've decided to build out a
machine learning tool so they can help
predict wildfires last year not even
just the summer in California alone we
had what was it nine thousand fires
burning approximately it was pretty bad
2200 square miles of forest yeah it was
really bad so they basically designed a
device using tensorflow machine learning
to visually assess where there might be
potential fire hazards and specifically
brush that may be so dry that it would
lead to the start of a fire so they've
implemented these devices in the forest
and have shown about 89 percent accuracy
rate and we'll include the link and then
show no it's really cool and they they
have a nice video on this as well
another cool thing of the week that we
wanted to mention and it's not as much
of a cool thing but it's an important
thing google.org right now is actually
matching donations they are collecting
money and distributing it to charities
that are helping with Puerto Rico's
continued recovery this of course being
the continued recovery from September
2017 s hurricane that hit Puerto Rico
and has severely impacted the island so
if you are still looking to have a
further impact in terms of helping the
recovery efforts if you donate money
before the 20th Google is matching up to
two million dollars of the donation and
a hundred percent of what you donate is
actually going to the different
charities that Google is is distributing
this funds to for the recovery efforts
the only fees that potentially could
happen is if you're out of the country
and there's some kind of fee for
conversion of currency but
so that everything's going to recovery
efforts so if you wanted to donate you
still want to donate please check it out
we'll include the link in the show notes
yes that's really really cool yeah
excellent got announced very recently
actually I'm really excited about this
so we're introducing sole tenant nodes
for Google compute engine so basically
this is this is kind of cool because
generally when you're using compute
engine or essentially multi-tenant so
there's a lovely visualization that sits
on the blog post that will link to about
how basically you know you could have
multiple VMs on a single physical
machine and we manage all that for you
with live migrations and all that kind
of stuff sometimes though that's not a
ideal scenario for whatever it is you're
building maybe there's certain
compliance and regulation that you're
required to comply with that means that
you have to be on a physical machine
that's only and solely operated by you
or solely tenant in by you and that
might be thing or maybe you run a
workload that is super fine-grained so
any kind of noisy neighbor type
situation like at a very very low level
could be potentially a problem for you
I'm thinking particularly in the gaming
space if you run dedicated game servers
I'm looking at all of you folks so yeah
but we're excited to announce the beta
availability of sole tenant nodes so
basically you're the only one on the
hardware yes they include in the notes
and how easy it is to start it up as
well as a link to pricing yep so that's
all available and ready for you to play
with now all right mark I think it's
time for us to go talk with Mandy so
super excited to have someone in the
studio that I met a long time ago
actually Mandy Chan who is the
development community manager for
actions on Google Mandy thank you so
much for joining us today happy to be
here thank you thank you that you're I'm
super excited to have you here I know
you've had a long and varied history
with with voice and working with this
platform but before we get stuck into
that can you tell us a little bit about
who you are what do you do here at
Google like what's your background sure
so I like to say that I'm voice a holic
I love this space
so when this things first came out I
would open a bank account just to try
The Voice application from a bank I
would get a Domino's Pizza to order
pizza also get a Fitbit to just try to
avoid vacations so that's how obsessed I
am with this base you're very passionate
yeah and I build many voice applications
and doing the process of building those
voice applications I got frustrated with
SML and if you don't know what SML is s
SML is a speech synthesis markup
language i create an open source project
called as a smell buta to help the voice
developers to make building SML easier
so that's who I am and now that I'm at
Google
I am the developer community manager for
the action on Google team and my role is
to engage with the developers by
creating practical tools and content
basically improving the developer
experience is like my goal
recently I work with my team to build to
collapse level 1 and level 2 so feel
free to try that and give us feedback so
for those who've never worked with s SML
what exactly is speech synthesis yeah
can't say the word but I'm close
anyway speech sense that the yeah this
is gonna be a fun language what exactly
does that mean what does that sis amount
actually mean specifically for somebody
who's never used it before a metaphor
that I like to give to people who are
technical or people who might not be
technical is basically for people with
technical is a markup XML my extensible
markup language and if you are web
developers and you know HTML HTML is a
markup language for the browser you
markup the test and for s SML it is the
markup language to give style to the
voice and I like to say that the
synthesizer is like the browser for the
HTML that's great
that's very helpful so what kind of
things can you do with us SML you can do
a lot of things with s SML so when we
speak sometimes we pause so if you want
the smart system to take a break and
pause you know some time post can mean
hesitations suspensions so you can put a
brick tag to pause and you can also
phone number like
five it can be june 25th as a date or it
can be like fraction like this many
different way to express number so and
also one of my favorite ssmall tag is
called for saudi and you can change your
voice by manipulating adjusting the
pitch the volume and the speed so I know
that in this space we emphasize on like
giving a persona for your voice
application and this is how SS ml can
help you create a persona I think you
have a demo don't you yes I do I do so
let me show you guys how we can create a
proc Sona by adjusting the prasada tag
and this is action on Google right yes
I'm actually just playing the ssme tag
in our action on Google console
simulator so this action on Google is
the platform that we provide for the
third-party developers to build action
for the Google system and what is action
action is I like to use another metaphor
like it's the verb that help people get
things done turn on the lights you turn
on the TV all these are verbs and action
make our life more productive and just
make your everyday life easier and let
me now demo SS ml in the action on
google simulator how powerful that is
hello with that says ml you can make
speech faster or make it slow you can
make it high or you can make it low you
can make it loud we're all three things
at once but first you can make these
felt colors like you B lue edit this to
try yourself so this is just a very
basic demo of how ssmall can give your
voice application of personality and if
we add some audio tag like for action on
Google platform we have a sound library
that have all kind of fun sounds like a
minimal sounds or like windows cracking
sounds like different sounds that you
can add to your voice applications and
for movie if you don't have background
music it won't be the same and
same thing for the voice application you
want to add the atmosphere the mood and
give the add some personality so you can
do this with you said with actions on
Google and this can be used for any
voice application so like anything it's
it could be used with assistant it could
be used with other platforms to platform
yes so what sort of things are you
seeing people do with these voice
actions many developers they have Bill
actions for games that's a pretty
popular categories and they also bill
for the home automations I'm still
looking forward to what's possible that
other developers can bill but right now
our games and smart home are the big two
categories and one of the game that I
can also demo and show you is called mix
lat and let me demo this from action so
this action basically allows you to mix
different musical instrument together
just using your voice command so give me
a dreamy guitar
[Music]
and I can at layer two it cool so this
is just one of them anyway that the
creativity and the imagination is like
unlimited it's all up to developers and
I'm really looking forward to what the
crazy amazing stuff that the developers
can be without platform what's something
you felt with it good crashes so the
first voice application I built is
called dr. speech and I'm a strong
believer to build applications that help
people and dr. speech is an act a voice
application that help people who speak
English as a second language to improve
the pronunciation because I was born and
raised in Hong Kong angus is my second
language and growing up I have this
electronic dictionary to learn how to
speak English
and when I discover a smarter system is
like entire new world to me I have the
environment here every day I'm forced to
speak English but people overseas they
don't have the environments so think
about how much we can do for people over
see if we have more educational actions
they can use it to help the children or
help people who have autism like
different ways that people can use math
system smart system to to learn
different things I like that point just
because I mean I remember when I was
trying to learn another language and
when you don't have someone to engage
with who also you ain't even if you did
if they make you feel small when you're
trying to engage with them it makes you
less interested in continuing to pursue
that language like you need it that's
why they keep saying children can lose
learn ease it more easily another
language it's just cuz people are more
patient typically technology or computer
is going to be it's not it doesn't have
emotions in the game that's that's so
great that that's what you worked on yes
I still want to see more actions that
focus on this area yeah go go focus on
the system get things done helping
people make their life more productive I
believe that education is the untapped
area for this
space that's amazing um sir if from a
developer perspective if somebody's like
oh this sounds really cool and I want to
build an action like what tools what
what stuff have we got available for
them to do that so we have action on
Google platform that's the place that
you should go first and also as I
mentioned earlier our team recently just
published to collapse level 1 and level
2 is absolutely beginner level and you
can quickly start building action on
Google from scratch and dial-up flow is
another platform that help people who
might not even know how to code that you
can build action quickly so let me
explain how our flow and action on
Google work together okay
so power flow provides a intuitive
graphical user interface to create
conversation or experience you program
in few example sentences of things that
a user might speak and then you can also
specify what values you need to get from
the user
it then used machine learnings to
understand the sentences and manage the
conversation the key part here is that
you no longer need to process the raw
strings dial up flow handle that for you
basically all the heavy lifting dialogue
flow does it all for you so that's how
action on Google and dial-up flow works
together and other than that our team
also create some amazing templates for
people to build action on Google with
coding experience in fact at i/o when I
gave demo at the sandbox I met a couple
teachers they stopped by the booth and
they were so excited that I can create
tools for my student to learn
interactively by using action on Google
and dialogue flow Thanks if I so if I
say say I'm a programmer and I want to
create an action see I assume and I'm
gonna code something to make that happen
and then how do I make that code do a
thing like I don't know turn on my
lights or open my gara
so for devices we have this google
assistant sdk but for voice application
that we can use with the google google
home the speaker alone as well as the
phone will have this action on Google
client library
so I recommend developers go to our
documentation page to learn all this new
terminologies and concepts and how to
create your own fulfillments the
fulfillments basically is the business
logic that your actions can do you can
get things done there's some connections
I think to fire basis functions or
something like yes yes so great
questions so our team highly recommend
developers to fight that use firebase
basically you just want the command my
firebase in it and then you can use the
function the firestore the database and
hosting everything in one place you can
create your action very quickly okay and
there's integration there between
actions and yes lovely where do you see
SML going s SML is a standard and it
means that there's multiple communities
or companies they have to agree on this
standard and I think the direction right
now is really going to where the
synthesized voice will become as good as
professional actors like at Google i/o
we announced that there are six voices
coming up for Google system and Google
we have ways that that can create almost
human-like voices so this is where I see
that maybe soon we will replace the
Acton address and the computer can just
speak like us and another thing I really
like to think of is emotion I mentioned
earlier this is a new way we can create
software and this is also the time that
we can give software personality by
using SS ml and this is where where I
see that the direction is going that way
and so having the emotion to make it
seem more authentic and more real and
closer to human like in a way yep oh and
one more thing I want to highlight is so
I mentioned as a semi standard and at
Google we really think outside of the
box
standards are just common texts that
different platform can use such as break
say s but we think out of the box to
create some customized s SML such as
media and politic this is unique to
action on Google platform and nobody
else has that and the media Tet allows
you to compose sounds parallel or
sequentially I think I gave a
presentation back in December 2017 in
New York that I'm not a musician myself
I would love to be SOVA SS ml and this
whole voice applications space allow me
to think why I'm a composer I'm a sound
designer that I can make something
really fun and people are using their
sound designer with voice sound designer
with music with different types of
various sounds that you have in the
background type of thing yes yes so I
know one of the pushback from IO was
that there was concerns about people
having assistant call up and talk to
them and and whether they'd be able to
recognize that it's a person or not and
there was a saw some feedback that was
saying you know we'll make sure it
identifies itself as a computer do you
have an opinion on on this realistic
voice being used from the computer like
any new technologies it takes time for
people to get used to it I think
personally I'm very light over minded
and creatives so I understand why people
are concerned the ethical about you know
turning a robot into a human for me I'm
a big fan for size 5 like I watched the
movie her and I am Star Trek as my
favorite TV show so I'm not against that
but I can also understand why people
have those concern and this is really a
big moment because in the past I like to
use this example like the TV we have to
like yeah that when you were young you
have to like go up to the TV hotel do
you think I am we didn't have remotes
yeah I was I was
no yeah those day without the remote you
have to go up to the TV and turn on the
knob and then we have remotes you know
and that was a luxury and now we don't
even need to have any physical button
and remote we can use our voice yeah
yeah so this is really a big big time
for us agreed agreed
so so when am I gonna be able to walk
into my house and be like turn on lights
and everything will work and I'll be
like start dinner you can you can do it
now with the light spot the peena-pod
I'm not quite sure but you might be able
to talk to your assistant like they're
your buddy yeah I think some I think
there's some examples of that out there
actually you can talk back to me
yeah so you mentioned this actually a
little bit before where you were talking
about Google assistant and then also the
fact that you could do voice Actions on
the phone do you see any difference
between those two at least even how
they're used or like like that just that
whole environment yes
so buting application for like action on
Google home specifically there's no
screen and when we build voice
applications we really have to think
about the dialogue the conversation is
like you are a script writer but when
you build for mobile apps or web
developments you don't need to think
about all this storytelling kind of how
you interact with another assistant
smart system and another thing is SS ml
of course and basically like the UX and
UI I like to think that the flow the
conversation flow is like the user
interface but SS ml is like the user
experience because who are you talking
to the personality that you're creating
for your voice applications and one
additional point about our building
voice application why is that so
different everything is like top-level
any point of the dialogue you have with
the system you don't need to click the
mobile or the browser the next page or
going back to a previous page you can
ask anything say anything at any point
of the time so that's great we talked a
little bit already about Reese or
and where people can learn more but do
you have any other favorite resources or
recommendations especially of people who
are interested in working with ss ml
definitely play around with the action
on google console the simulator and use
my library of course are you gonna be
speaking anywhere soon doing any demos
soon somewhere else outside of i/o I was
a speaker at Grace Hopper last year
talking about my open source and this
year I am continuing the partnership
with sisters so sisters is a branch
under a leader board and a leader board
and sister are the organization who
create the once a year the largest woman
engineer conference Grace Hopper so on
June 21st and July 31st
I am partnering with the sister
community to do two online workshops to
teach more women how to build action on
Google so we will share the link on the
website again and all this resource
about how to build your first action on
Google everything will be shared on the
website right absolutely absolutely oh I
thought of just one thing I wanted to
ask you too we've seen really cool
examples that they're just thinking
around like i/o and stuff where people
do voice actions where there's context
so like a follow-up question I might be
like so tell me more about this
particular sports game and then I'll say
something like who was the top player
and it knows that the context is the
original like this that sports game
you'd like it how are you supports game
is there is there anything inside like
actions in Google or that that ecosystem
that handles that kind of thing to make
that sort of bit easier maybe yes that's
a game where that I love flow sharing so
they have a lot of interesting and
powerful concepts when it comes to
building a conversation of experience
and in fact the concept is called
contacts yes so you're right that when
we use voice application it will be nice
that they don't have to keep asking you
what are the artists that you just play
the music if you listen to once on and
you wanna say more the assistant know
that you already chose John Legend and
when you say play more it will just play
more of John Legend's music and that
concept is called context and another
interesting concept is called
lifespan that dialogue for provides and
I like to describe lifespan like our
like us we have short-term memory in a
conversation there's multiple turns back
and forth for life I've lifespan mean 5
turns
if we keep talking about some random
things then we the lifespan will expire
like our short-term memory we can't keep
talking about something random and just
lose focus so this concept is really
powerful in voice applications to give
assistance short-term memory there are
so many layers to just voice
conversations that I've never even
thought about like you're talking about
tone and intonation and that stuff and
I'm basically having how the UI can
affect how your conversation happens a
super fascinating communications complex
and thus it's also this is why this
problem is not an easy one to solve but
but we've made a lot of progress we
definitely makes lots of progress and
with the developers I think that's why
we open up the platforms and we really
want developers play around with our
platform and innovate together with
Google progressive like the open source
concept like more people contribute the
better the technology becomes same thing
for voice space what languages do we
work with right now in terms of action
on Google we have many many languages I
can't even recall I think we have 16
languages and by language you mean
programming language or do you mean like
voice language just to be clear good
question so programming language in
terms of programming language right now
our client library is written in ogs but
in terms of like common knowledge that
the Google system is available I need to
go back and look at how many countries
but I think is available out there 16
languages
we'll have a link to double-check that's
okay we don't have to know it right this
minute but yeah but that's great that's
good to know
well cool before we wrap up we already
had time just a smidge this has been
great
is there anything else you want to make
sure it gets mentioned or you plug or
wait wait I think I need to show this
this is really maximizing the use of SS
ml and all this sound library from giant
cat monsters giant tornado King and
that's when things got knocked into 12th
year so this is how you can use SSM out
to create a story like it's great for
building actions for kids for games for
party gate like anything like that as it
smells powerful and the demo that I just
showed you is really maximizing the
usage of SSS ml and our team actually
wrote a blog post it's called events SS
ml for action on Google or medium so
feel free to look that up definitely go
to action on Google documentation page
and also we recently have a new
conversation design page so I think I
mentioned earlier that this space is
different that you need to write before
you even code that you need to write the
dialogue before you call so it's good
practice that if you have a conversation
designer great if you don't but you can
still go to our conversation don't
decide website to learn about the best
practice many things can go wrong in our
voice applications and in invoice
there's no errors so go to the website
and learn about how you can create the
best possible experience for your users
that's great well thank you we really
appreciate you coming on Mandy and
telling us all about actions on Google
thank you so much yeah thanks so much
I have fun I have fun demoing there the
applications and this is really the
space I enjoy so much I don't consider
myself I'm
working I'm considering myself having
fun right now and share my passions and
inspire more developers to build on
action on Google it's wonderful so and
join me on June 21st if you ever want to
learn how to peel action on Google its
online virtual web shop you can sit at
home and learn how to build a fantastic
yeah oh thank you well thank you very
much thank you thank you again Mandy
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast and telling us all about actions
on Google and getting to play around
with sounds I like playing around with
sounds yeah sounds great
they are so does our editors or editors
likes ads as well well okay mark I want
to push your docker image to Google
container registry via docker push so
how can I do that so don't have to use
g-cloud docker - - push every time well
that's an excellent question Mandy
that's right I'm Andy your Maddy well
that's an excellent question Melanie I'm
so glad that you asked the question that
I asked you to ask it's very convenient
how we work that out yeah exactly
so I wanted to talk about this for a
couple of reasons one of which is
sometimes it's just easier or more ideal
to simply say like hey doctor push
rather than using the g-cloud command to
do some stuff maybe see our pipelines
that kind of stuff but the other side of
this is actually also some things around
deprecation as well we'll start at the
top level so if you want to simply be
able to say duck or push or duck or pull
from a container registry using your
g-cloud authentication there's a command
you can run called g-cloud or configure
docker and what that'll do is that'll
set up some handlers as some credential
helpers within your docker credentials
and set things up basically so it's
essentially a seamless process this is
the preferred way we strongly recommend
that you use this method whenever
possible it provides secure short-lived
access to your project resources if I
read the documentation and so basically
that is the way so if you ever find that
you're having issues with say g-cloud
docker for any reason use this instead
it's definitely much better but it's
worth noting then for this very reason
that g-cloud docker is currently only
recommended for docker client versions
older than 1.1 3 which don't support the
use of credential helpers or anything
like that
so it's worth noting that I've seen
people try and use g-cloud talker with
newer versions of docker and sometimes
it didn't work and people go confused
and that kind of stuff so if you're on a
new version of docker
use the credential
there's g-cloud both configure Ducker
and that'll make your lives all that
easier it's worth noting if you really
really really really really really
really really don't want to use that for
some weird reason or you want to set up
individual short-lived tokens just for a
very short period you can do that as
well there's a link to it in the
documentation there's an advanced
authentication thing you can you can
still do that yourself if you need to
but generally speaking use g-cloud Olaf
configure docker and you are good to go
great all right mark going anywhere
speaking anywhere anytime soon yes so
yes I am speaking so I'll be speaking at
the kubernetes San Francisco meetup on
the 14th of June giving a little demo of
a gun is and talking about that I'll
also be talking at the kubernetes
community meeting on the 21st that's an
online meeting I'll put some details for
that also in the show notes so I'll also
be talking about organize as well what
are you up to I am speaking at a joint
women and machine learning a data
science and PI ladies event that's
titled past two data sites on June 26
and I will also be speaking at AI for
all on June 28 No yeah awesome
looking forward to it mark I think
that's it for us for this week it was
fun it was really fun with Mandy I'm
glad we got a chance to finally do that
cuz I know you've been wanting to do
that for a while yeah I agree there were
some really great little sound bites and
fun sound things that happened some bits
and bytes and all the things yeah we've
got some fun stuff out of that settle
ISM thanks Melanie for joining me for
yet another week on the podcast thank
you and thanks everyone for listening
and we'll see you all next week
and as emphasizing and I can add more
layer and a relaxing guitar
[Music]
and a John Machine play it underwater
[Music]
yeah there's all kind of fun songs you
can add many many layers that's why I
feel like I'm a musician or for composer
just by playing with voice applications
[Music]